they were broken and Bloated bodies of
Russian soldiers on the road into Lehman
as we entered
Testament to the Ambush wrought on them
by a Ukrainian Force Bent On retaking
This Town
in amongst the dead we saw minds too the
retreating Army wanted to kill as they
were being pushed back
inside the Strategic eastern city the
battle to reclaim it has left it in
tatters Street after Street has been hit
there are only the symbols of the
occupation left behind and constant
signs of looting with emptied cash
machines and shops including pharmacies
broken into and pillaged
the police station still has its signage
and Russian but the gate has been
freshly painted over with the blue and
yellow colors of the Ukrainian flag just
a few days earlier this is what it
looked like
Russian Flags which once flew here have
been burned the landscape's
fast-changing right now and this Victory
came easily the soldiers say
and here in Lehman oh so so Russians go
away
a little shoot
go away the ukrainians insist there's
more of the same to come but how quickly
is an unknown
it's hard to answer this question
because the weather can change but we
hope you'll be fast and we'll see
Russia had used Lehman as a vital
transport Hub its railway lines were key
to supplying its troops in Donetsk one
half of the donbass as well as its
military in the second half lahansk and
they were in control here for months
the two sides had been fighting over it
ever since and it's badly battle scarred
even hospitals weren't spared
the residents who remained here are wary
of just about everything being called
Russian collaborators because they
stayed
as well as surviving a fast approaching
winter
every passing military vehicle is
glanced at anxiously the Russian Zed has
a Ukrainian cross now over it what is it
you're worried about are you what fear
you fearful of the ukrainians or you're
fearful of the Russians or both War over
land he says but we've got nothing to
heat our houses no electricity nothing
this whole area according to Vladimir
Putin is now Russia but those we spoke
to said they hadn't voted because of
fighting and they have other more
pressing worries
we don't care who's in control here it
could be the devil she says we just want
them to stop shooting
the town has virtually emptied and those
left have no power no water and have
survived under a barrage of missiles and
Rockets dislodging the Russians has come
at a price but leaving wasn't an option
for these people
foreign
camonada
Natalia shows us the shelters they've
been living in dark and cold and about
to get much colder
the Ukrainian police have returned to
their old jobs tried to offer some hope
it's just our second day here dimitro
says we can't fix everything at once we
know you need it
they've survived but this war has left
them with barely a life
and already the troops have moved
forward to try to recapture more land
once they have the momentum Alex
Crawford Sky News in Lehman in eastern
Ukraine